第一章早年的学习与经历
每个人生长历程
家庭环境不一样
这便造就每个人不同的个性
价值观和心态
而心态则是交易最重要的一部分
没有稳定的投资心态
任何技术都是空谈
在此
我概述一下自己的生长历程
除了作为论述投资心态的影子以外
也满足一些读者
粉丝的好奇心
很多人猜测我家财万贯
有些人则猜测我是高学历知识分子
还有些人猜测我跟随名师
然而
这些猜测全都落空了
事实上
我的家庭远比这些人的猜测
要来得普通许多
不过
我生长在父亲是国中自然老师
母亲是高中化学老师的小康家庭
从小到大
可说是在无忧无虑的生长环境下长大
这一点算是非常幸运
或许
如果我从小到大饿住肚子
一开始交易
目的就是为了盼翻身
盼财富
交易这条路恐怕也走不到今天了
关于这一点
接下来的篇章也会提到原因
小时候的我
可以说是一个问题儿童
明明是个爱看书的孩子
但就对学校的书本感到厌烦
从小学开始
我的成绩始终是吊车尾
都是班上
全校最后几名
只爱打篮球的我
第一次国中升高中基策
还没能考上高中
后来才侥幸分数低分飞过
上了一所桃园私立高中
这边不得不提到当时的能力分校
分班是一个很好的政策
依据能力分班
同学的状况都一样
教学过程可以更深入了解同学的状况
老师付出的耐心与理解也会更直觉
不会因为参差不齐的水准而使得授课方式受限
更能设定适当的标准
付出爱心与时间来对待我们
一包饼前
造就了日后的交易巨人
我很幸运
遇到一群没什么经验
刚出社会工作
年轻有活力的老师
正是他们不受框架限制的教育方式
改变了我的一生
这些年轻导师
对教育满怀热忱
没有放弃我们这些成绩烂道报的学生
除了防止我们继续走歪以外
下课甚至还陪着我们打篮球
求学历程中
我每天从早到晚待在学校
耗在漫长而繁多的课程里
然而
我除了篮球外
只对吃东西有兴趣
升上高中后
我仍是这样迷糊混日子
就这样过了一两年
某天
年轻的数学老师
为了让我愿意好好坐在教室听课
这样要求我
你可以去福利社买一包饼钱
坐在第一排吃饼钱听我讲课
这位老师到现在还不知道
就是这一句话
改变了我的一生
对当时的我来说
能在上课时吃东西
是多大的诱因
也因为这一包饼钱
我开始试着听课
听着听着就对数字产生一点兴趣
也突然注意到
原来不是所有科目都很无聊
于是慢慢地享受到学习知识的乐趣
因此
我也才发现自己先前的根基实在太差
连国中程度都没有
于是很下决心
高三请了几乎一年的假
独自一人去书店找国中教材
默默地从国异程度开始学习
就这样一路读书
最后读进政治大学
还从研究所毕业
学习必须有兴趣才能学得好
学得扎实或许也是正
众刊称一路自学上来的摸索
钻研过程让我在日后
自学交易的路上走得更加顺遂
交易是父母为我开的最后一扇门
再来谈谈我的家庭
由于双亲都是老师
理所当然的希望将自家小孩教育得非常优秀
才不愧教师的名声
从小到大
他们就像台湾许多望子成龙的家长一样
努力栽培我各种才艺技能
从英文 钢琴 吉他 树笛
这些却没有一项让我打从心里感到有趣
尝试这么多 我还是只喜欢打篮球
虽说那些课程没有一项能让我感兴趣
但像这样多方尝试的教育方法
我认为是对的
学生时期成本很低
应该多去尝试 开辟各种道路
谁也不知道这些尝试
是否能在未来的人生中开花结果
顺带一提
我也认为学生时期是最适合做交易
成本也最低的时期
详情后文会再提及
有趣的是
我父母亲不知道为什么会想让我学习音乐
我明明是粗广又大致的
190公分巨汉
怎么看都跟音乐没有关系吧
值得庆幸的是
当我父母亲终于放弃让我学习
各式各样的才艺技能之后
他们为我开了人生最后一条路
带着未满18岁的我
去住家隔壁的小券商开户
他们只对我说
你研究看看
然后我也将他们平时给我的零用钱
凑成一万元
作为我初始的本金莫想到
就是这条模
一间尝试
的道路
最后却成了我赖以为生的职业与兴趣
满18岁
一头撞进交易这条路
父母亲带我去开的第一个证券户头
是一家仅在桃源营业的在地小券商
那家券商里面有些昏暗
整个分点仅有不到5名营业员
是因为未满18岁
开户还需要两个监护人陪同
并授权同意
至今我还记得
第一次开户交易
手续费65折
小台手续费100元
大台手续费200元
当时这家小券商只提供投资人
在网页上手动输入下单的服务
很快的
这样的服务便不能满足我了
于是我自行上网搜寻
发现那时
其他券商已经推出闪电下单的服务
所以一满18岁
我立刻骑着机车
前往市区找了一间大型的证券商开户
时至今日
我对那次自行开户的印象
还是相当深刻
当年我一个小矛头走进去
许多柜台人员看住我
却没有人来招呼
我想开户
我自己开口
于是柜员勉为其难地让我过去
拿出一叠开户资料
让我自行填写
写完
再请我上网
自行查询他们
官网上的说明
包括如何使用软体
如何下单等
当时懵懂的我
连自己的营业员是谁也不知道
完全一无所知
但当下我满心雀跃
隔天
我兴高采烈地跑到学校图书馆
急切地打开券商网站四处探寻
还下载券商软体
终于在软体中
发现我很想要的功能闪电下单家
一股难以言喻的兴奋涌上心头
哇 既然用点的就可以做买卖
不用输入价格
不用经过一连串繁琐的程序
输入标的 价格 张数 送出
就可以下单
这对当时那个刚满18岁的我来说
宛如打开新世界那般的感动
自从我有了闪电下单加这个东西以后
每天就算没有买卖股票
光看住闪电下单加的数字跳动
模拟下单状况
滑鼠跟住上下移动
我也跟住幻想自己正在交易
也是相当满足
可以说是因为闪电下单价的存在
才让我更对投资买卖这个游戏深深注迷
对当时的我而言
这完全就像是在打电动一样
这样自行摸索
逐渐奠基初期至今的交易方向短线交易
时到今日
我一个人的成交量
已经远超过这整个分点
所有客户加总的成交量数倍
这想必是当初见到那个
自己跑来开户的矛头小子
却没人愿意接待的券商柜台人员们
难以想象的是吧
第二章出入股市大官员
回想我最初接触股市的那段时间
当时的我可能跟大多数人一样
看到电视上财经频道
尤其那些名嘴分析师
唱作俱佳
精彩不输八点档的表演
不免眼花缭乱
沉溺于价格不断跳动的数字游戏中刚开始
我并未正式下单
只是先盯住盘式观察
还是股市新手的我
对于这类财经频道也是相当热衷
记得当时的财经频道57台或58台
有两位分析师
分别信于合章
他们总在前后十段出演
除了提供投资建议以外
更多的就是隔空护枪
精彩热闹犹如连续剧
枪的当然就是彼此的标的投资绩效
我赚100
你赚50
标的上还贴着便利贴
又印出早上他们发给会员的讯息
掉足了观众的胃口
我想在这样热烈的斗争气氛下
每个人都会想进场尝试一下的
当然我也不例外
那时初入股市的我
也被这些花招所吸引
一心觉得他们好厉害
于是原本喜欢打电动看电视的我
由于对这个投资游戏过于痴迷
突然就没兴趣打电动
也不想看连续剧了
股市的上上下下彻底震撼我
让我每天满脑子想的
都是追看股市的后续发展
还记得
那时只要遇到股市修饰
或是要去上课的时段
我的心情就会陷入
深深的沮丧之中
简直是上瘾了
每天一心一意地关注股市
只想着开盘
因因期盼数字赶快继续跳动
尽管开盘后
可能赚钱也可能赔钱
甚至还是赔钱居多
我仍然乐此不疲
除了看这些分析师表演以外
我也紧盯着电视上
那些红绿色的报价跳动不放
尤其是盘中财经频道
又下角大单区块
真的是一眼都舍不得放过
看到那么庞大的数字
当年的我只想着
这是什么样的世界啊
怎么有人一笔就买进几千万的股票
那可是能买下一栋房子的钱啊
对十几岁的我而言
这是完全无法想象的事情
有趣的是
我明明有红绿色盲
电视上报价的红绿色
我却从来没有分不清楚过
尽管当时买卖次数
经验都还很少
盘中也不知道在看什么
电视频道到处乱转
拉虎股市到处乱看
但光看住这些五花八门的表演和股价的上下跳动
就足以让我热血沸腾
每天沉浸在这些数字的波动里
直到现在
我还记得开户完没多久
我躺在床上
思考一些很杂乱的问题
而这些问题纠缠了我数年之久
为什么股价会跳动
为什么有人赚得到钱
股市的逻辑
规律是什么
为什么那些分析师可以这样轻松赚钱
股价到底怎么预测
翻遍投资书籍
窥见股市的光与尹开户这一年
我才17岁左右
正式上大一的年纪
这时
同侪
朋友们每天讨论去哪里吃
去哪里玩
而我除了上课念书之外
却是买手于投资相关的书籍中
整天在学校图书馆疯狂阅读
恨不得马上把市上所有投资相关书籍全部看完
当时有几本书令我印象深刻
像是大家较熟悉的张松允从十万赚十亿
这本书让我对股市有着无比的想象空间
书中提及损益动辄几千万
甚至上亿元的金额
对于一个学生来说
非常震撼
十几年后的现在
我自己的赚赔损益
有时也是每日千万元在跳动
想一想也是不可思议
但更不可思议的是
当时学校图书馆
既然收藏一本叫做《古董章回忆录》的书
当时的我当然不知道《古董章》编案
股市名嘴
知名炒作者
曾因炒作股票不法得利而入狱是谁
而且这本书是一本非常冷门的书籍
却令我留下十分深刻的印象
为什么呢
主要是因为这本书的内容
实在是跟其他财经书籍差异太大了
内容主要是一些股市内幕
包括收钱炒股
收买名嘴
拉抬特定股票
并吞公司等
印象中我看的目瞪口呆
嘴巴奇指合不起来
甚至快掉下来了
这本书末提到什么
关于策略
操作
的内容我却来回翻了书遍深深惊叹于股市到底是什么样的世界啊这本书也让我奠定一些重要观念原来股票市场绝对不是人人公平的世界
原来股票市场并不是看线图分析就可以破解的
原来股市是这么复杂的游戏
2024年的现在
对比十几年前时代已经不同了
当今ETF盛行
多档ETF受益人数甚至多达百万人
当年书中写的那个年代
公司要出货拉抬股价
要跟那些电视上的投顾老师配合
才能吸引得到买盘
现在公司派大股东或是大户要出货
只要找一个把ETF规则或指数编列规则
研究到很彻底的人
就可以计算出自家股票要达到什么条件
才会被纳入某些特定的ETF或指数
以及什么时候会有被动型基金来买公司的股票
可以出货多少股票
没错
现在这些都可以轻易地被操作出来
举例来说
现在最盛行的高股息ETF
撇除一些纳入的必要条件
各ETF规则
条件都不同
例如流动性
成交量
然后再把当年股力拉高
就可以有机会被纳入ETF的编列之中
这部分可以只有把一些收益
灌进当年度
或者配发位分配盈余等方式来达成
当然
还有数种拉高当年殖利率的做法
若是隔年顺利进入ETF的清单
那么除了市场上原有的买盘以外
就多了许多被动型买盘
那可是几亿 几十亿的买盘
这不仅能运用在ETF
也可以预测哪些股票有望纳入MSCI
富时等指数
这些都是被很多外资追踪的重要指数
这也难怪
一些热门股在股价高档时
外资 投信总是会大笔买进
而大户也能在高档轻松出货了
第三章第一次买股票
不赚不赔
平凡无期的初次下单
在初次下单之前
我一直持续模拟研究
那时最常使用的网站是
Rahu奇摩股市
说真的
一开始根本没有方向
只会乱看乱摸索
对一个18岁的人来说
认识的公司实在有限
新闻更是完全看不懂
虽然什么都不懂
我还是用蛮干的方式
每看到一档新的标的
都会去打开它的走势图
过程中
我偶然看到一档叫做友达的股票
当时股价在九元附近
我欣喜地发现
这档股票一张才九千元
我买得起
而且还是一家隐约好像有听过的公司
于是快速打开下单家
买进一张友达
当系统跳出成交通知的时候
我感受到一种优越感
成就感
我在交易股票了
当朋友们还在打电动
追剧的时候
我竟然在买卖股票
这感觉实在是太酷了
买进后
荧幕上显示着我的损益
正在不断跳动
虽然我买进这张股票的损益波动
只有几十元左右
但当下
我的眼睛却是紧盯住
不放
紧张到甚至能清楚地感受到
自己的呼吸和心跳
这次人生初体验的结果还可以
没多久就把这一单卖出
小赚几十元出场
但终究是完成了人生的第一笔交易
第一笔投资
第一笔短线交易
也加深了我对投资的兴趣
凑出50万
准备大展身手
初体验的感觉很美好
后来我又鍥而不舍地持续搜寻
当时当然没什么股票筛选器
利用软体筛选标的的概念
因此我找了很久
却发现都找不到我现有本金可以买进
也就是一张小于1万元的标的
于是想着
我需要更多钱
便把从小到大
父母亲给的红包钱
平时存的零用钱
还有父母亲从小帮我存的定存解约
凑一凑大约将近50万元
作为自己投资的本金
或许是因为我的个性使然
即使凑出这笔50万本金
我的心态
仍与其他人有钱
就频繁交易的状况不太一样
这50万对当时的自己来说
已经算是天文数字
毕竟在这之前
我的生命经历中
大概只买过一台1万多元的HTC手机
那就是我人生中最贵的奢侈消费
正因如此
我认为在正式动用这笔大钱之前
自己应该多充实投资知识
于是我做了人生第一个研究
开一个Excel表
将台湾股市中1000多档股票
统统抓出来
从1101开始列
编案辞职股票代码
台股原先依据产业别
由1101开始编号
但近期新股编号方式已有所不同
我一档一档的输入
希望能够借此快速地增加
自己的股票常识与投资知识
这时候也发现一个很好用的网站叫做
莫尼DJ
虽然这网站资料有些过时
但对那时出入股市的我已经够用了
当时只要在Google搜寻1101米
就会有这家公司的基本介绍
范例如下
台湾水泥股份有限公司
公司成立于中华民国35年
是台湾一家水泥
集域办混凝土制造商
生产线遍布两岸
是台湾第一大
大陆前世大水泥厂
于民国51年在台湾证券交易所上市
简称台尼
代码1101TW
当时的我花了许多时间
把所有股票基本资料都看过一轮后才发现
其实台湾产业真的很强
可能有将近两成的公司
都会有一个很响亮的名号是
台湾地成已大
全球地成已大
诸如此类
看完之后
我开始交易了吗
没有
老实说
当我看完这些之后
却发现还是不知道怎么交易
于是我走进了书局
想找找财经书
一踏入财经书专区
映入眼帘的都是技术分析类的书籍
例如股市圣经
技术分析圣经
都张图看懂技术分析
轻松抓住标股足繁不及被彩
阅读这些书籍
让我走入了下一个阶段
钻研各种指标
我要成为技术分析王
喜欢看书的我
就这样每天沉迷在书局
图书馆的财经区
一本又一本地看
每一本都不放过
就这样买了一堆书
借了一堆书
每天都会带着一台笔电
跑到图书馆的角落
边看书边从看盘软体中
寻觅与书里一样的标的
一样的日期区间
一样的指标
这时的我
每天这个方法试一试
那个方法也试一试
疯狂地沉迷在各个指标
各个酷炫的名词中
从什么Mark到123ABC波
到什么支撑压力
什么费波那奇数列
量价关系
裸K
每天都看一堆线
画一堆线
还记得当时的我
只要每次研究到一个新东西
就会非常的兴奋
一心想着
被我找到了吧
就是这个方法了
是的
当时的我也梦想着
要找到一个最厉害的操盘方法
能在所有标的都使用
而且是可以买在最低
卖在最高
也不会被盘整洗掉的方法
为了找出这个方法
在此同时
我也到处听人家的演讲
到处上课
还记得那时一堂课
一天大概都要四千元左右
有些讲义或书籍
甚至一本要接近万元
宛如武功秘技
对于学生时期
还没什么本金的我来说
这真的是非常大的一笔开销
但对于对市场深深怀抱梦想
又很有热忱的那个矛头小子来说
当然宁愿饿着肚子
减少玩乐开销
也一定要找到这个绝世武功
我每次只要找到一个新的方法
除了疯狂地做回策
对照历史线图
看看是不是真的如同书中
课程中讲的一样灵艳外
甚至还会大言不惭地自夸
你们这些老师只会一个方法
我全部都专精
我就超越你们了
于是
MACD加KD加RSI加SMA加波浪理论
加量价关系加K线形态加
没错
我的看盘软体就放了那么多的指标
看中那堆指标
我的心中充满了得意
我成为指标大师了
我终于成为技术分析的王者了
还记得
当时回到老家
老妈在厨房煮菜
我就在旁边匕首画脚说着
你看这只股票走势
现在就是处在什么阶段
一二三四五波
你猜接下来会怎么走
就这样在厨房内
滔滔不绝地进行一连串的分析
现在是上涨量缩
现在是均线黄金交叉
每一只股票
我都可以分析得头头是道
加上各种指标的解析
我真是由衷佩服自己
果然是当之无愧的技术分析王者
当时的老妈在我滔滔不绝的同时
竟然还持续地发问
对我表示崇拜
不知道是想让我有成就感呢
还是该说
难怪市场上会有那么多老师开课
都轻松爆满
一堂几十万
几百万入带
原来那么好赚啊
结果呢
我因为技术分析赚爆或赔爆了吗
出事提升的大胆决策
至今仍受用无穷转眼间
已经过了两三年
当我觉得自己成为技术分析王者
没有看不懂的股票走势后
我便自告奋勇地跟父母亲说
让我来帮你们投资吧
我的父母亲都是老师
时常听着同事讨论股票
看新闻就进行买卖
而我这位技术分析王
每天也总是在家中长篇大论的分析
预测股价接下来怎么走
久而久之
父母亲已经是我分享投资研究心得的最佳听众
虽然在那几年尝试的过程中
我也累积了不少交易经验
但其实我的本金并没有增加
不过父母看到我研究的精神与时间
大概就理所当然地认为我比较专业
于是便给我证券户的账号密码
我登入后
发现父母亲的股票库存
只有两只股票
分别为宏达电 台积电
我便迅速打开我的珍藏指标
有十几种之多
看盘软体界面
当下内心胸有成竹
这些股票
未来不就是会这样走吗
让我来吧
当时爸妈的库存状况
大致如下
宏达店库存成本约为300到400元
但股价已经腰斩
股价大约在150元左右
非常刚好的是
当年2015年的台积电股价
也差不多在150元左右
而库存成本大概是60元
宏达店持股约六张
成本约为200万
台积电也是6张左右
成本约36万
但账面上台积电是赚钱的
当时我看了宏达电
不经直摇头
这不就破线停损
指标翻空就好嘛
又看了台积电
还是摇头
赚那么多钱
已经获利100以上了
还不获利了结
到时跌下来
不就跟宏达电一起赔钱
于是我迅速拟定了交易策略
隔天宏达电开盘若下沙
我就全数停损
台积电不管怎样就是出场
获利入贷
结果隔天开盘
宏达电还真的开低
我就依照我盘前的策略
全数出清
大约是父母亲成本五折的价格
由于这六张宏达电
父母亲已经持有套牢三年多
虽然套牢了很久
他们内心却总是盼望这只股票
有天会重返荣耀
于是知道我出清之后
我很快就接到了老爸的来电
询问为何要卖掉
让他们赔了百万元
当下的我
当然对自己的决定深信不已
我只说
你等住看
结果还真的从我出清之后
这只股票后面又持续的腰斩
至于台积电也被出清了
爸妈惋惜的说着
台积电是台湾最好的公司
你为什么要卖掉
我只回答他们
涨好多了
初次进行的这两笔大单
堪称是影响我后面十多年交易旅程
非常重要的两笔交易
随着时间过去
我的功力不断变强
但我每次回想这两笔交易
都会产生很不一样的看法
直到今日
第四章逐渐理解股市真相
渐渐明白股市赚钱没那么简单在我持续看盘交易以及不设限的大量阅读、大量的看网路上的资讯后,我才渐渐的了解到金融市场的轮廓。
市场没那么简单
是我累积不少交易经验后的感想
曾经意气风发
立志成为技术分析王者的我
看住自己的对账单
虽没赔钱
但也没赚钱
这个结果不禁让我感到纳闷
不是只要等指标转强买进
抱着就可以吃一大段吗
为什么会这样被洗呢
而且为什么我用了更多指标之后
却好像变成更抱不住了
理论上
只要等突破均线买进
抱着均线就可以赚一百
那这些所谓轻松赚的钱呢
为什么没有出现在我的对账单上
于是乎
我终于知道
股市赚钱没那么简单
股票市场上绝不是用几条均线
几个指标就可以轻松躺着赚到钱
难怪股市有那么多人赔钱
也难怪即使股市在涨
也没有人人成为富翁
如今来看
很多人都是像我一样
研究过技术分析后
进场却失利
于是开始对股票市场可以赚价差感到怀疑
也难怪很多长期投资的老师
会质疑这些靠价差赚钱的人的真实性
但当时的我宁愿相信网路上那些神人的对账单
或是这些古海传奇人物是真的
宁愿选择做梦
也不愿选择放弃
我也相信每个行业都有成功的人
既然我对股票市场有兴趣
就应该要更努力
于是我更认真地找寻各种方法
每天花的时间越来越多
这时一天已经差不多花十小时在股市上
包含盘中
盘后时间
除了买股票以外
我也开始学着放空
并接触股票之外的期货商品
这时交易的是台纸期
操作方式主要还是用技术分析
搭配个人对市场的看法
感觉由于多控都可以做
我的交易频率开始显著上升
因此更加迅速累积市场经验
那时
我的股海生涯已经过了三
四年
可能很多人觉得一个人有多少四年可以这样花费
也一定有人会说
我才不愿意让自家孩子这样浪费青春
只花在股市上不去接触其他的嗜好或学习呢
但其实现在来看
这段时间我若没有学习股市相关知识
可能也只是把时间拿来休闲娱乐而已
当然不是说休息不好
但在此我要再次提起这个观念
学生时期最适合拿来练交易
2015年
我迎来交易生涯的第一个转折点
踏出技术分析舒适圈
大量学习与交易
很常有人问我
你会看技术面
技术分析吗
初学的我会回复
当然会看
我会看什么指标搭配
讯号出现后
股价会怎么涨
有点惊艳之后的我会回复
不太看了
指标都是落后的
我现在不太看指标
但会看价量关系等
因为这才是最快反映市场的指标
现在的我会回复
当然会看
因为我没办法把所有股票的所有走势背起来
现在对我来说
技术分析就只是用来记录价格的走势
变化
也因为这个领悟
我不再去追求什么市场的圣杯
数学系的我
曾经想着要找出几条公式
破解全市场涨跌的密码
但现在的我知道
根本就没有这种公式
因为影响股价的因子实在太多
会想要找出公式
期盼光靠技术分析就能破解全部的总视
并且将这一套运用在股市中赚钱的最主要原因
还是总结为太想轻松赚钱
毕竟只要跨出K线图
外面的世界看起来就好复杂
所以处在这个阶段的人会用重种说法来说服自己和他人
例如股价会反映所有的资讯
你没有内线也没有消息
去研究其他的也只是浪费时间
一切还是要回归股价
用这些理由来说服自己
继续钻研技术分析
我当然没有这种逃避的心态
我是学术学和统计的
在领悟到股市不是单纯画线的游戏后
我发现
这样子看来
搞不好那些念财经系的学生都比我厉害
我向来在学习方面从不服输
大学毕业要考研究所时
因为桃园地区大多数学生
都是到某两家补习班补习
有时A补习班猜提准
有时却是B补习班奖的课程
跟考试内容较为接近
于是我便同时报名两家补习班
以便吸收他们所有的课程内容
我秉持着他们会的
我全都要会的心态
一头钻进财经系学生的领域
为了彻底吸收
我直接排满所有课表
从周一到周五
全部都去旁听
这段时间内
我上的课程包括
产业分析
不动产经济
企业并购
各经
总经
会计
财务工程
衍生性金融商品等
很多人说
学术和实物差太远了
其实不是这样的
学会这些东西
能让你做交易
比别人更高一个层次
例如财务工程和会计
我到现在都觉得十分受用
你看得懂财报
看得懂期货
选择权是怎么定价
怎么报价的话
就可以灵活思考
推导出非常多的策略
事实上
很多大户即使在学生时期
没有去学会这些知识
当他们在交易过程中
察觉到这项领域知识的重要性后
他们也会去补齐
举例来说
交易期货选择权
想过他们是怎么定价的吗
买卖权评价关系
破靠Parity是所有学习财务工程的人
最基础的知识
但在市场上
却有许多人交易了十多年
仍然不知道期货与选择权的联动关系
为了学习这堆知识
当时我的行程排得非常紧密
那段时期
我每天早上八点起床
但基本上都要到半夜两三点才会入睡
每天都忙着上课
看盘
复习
交易研究等
尽管如此忙碌
但在上这些学科时
我跟旁边对学习感到厌倦
而显得一脸厌世的同学们完全不同
如果当时有人注意到我
一定会发现我露出发光的眼睛
因为我边上课边想的是
哇
真如这些书上写的一样吗
我等一下一定要去验证看看
然后再把这些衍生成一个策略来测试
举例来说
应该所有经济系
财经系的学生都学过货币理论
总体经济
不过大多数学生在学习到生息
对货币资金流向的影响时
可能是听完
背起来就结束了
而我则不止如此
我会运用这些知识来交易货币
并且在课后疯狂地寻找各国股市
会市的资料
拿来比对生息
降息等政策的影响
并且构思
下次若我再遇到这些情况
该怎么在其中赚取钱财
正因为这样广泛
不设限的大量接触
大量交易
这段期间我练功练得很快
连自己都感受得到
我已经跳脱出新手的框架
2015年
台股盘整许久之后
终于突破1万点了
4月27日至28日
这也是当时最热门的新闻话题
整体市场气氛非常乐观
然而
指数达到五位数关卡后
却只维持了两天
随后便开始下跌
当时我判断
大盘已跌破万点
而考量到前几天市场大量进场追高的成本
短期之内再创高点的几率不高
最有可能的就是走跌与盘涨
因此
我开始尝试布局放空
包含台纸期和一篮子股票
我拟定的策略是
大盘若过高就全部停损
衡量上涨几率不高
且赔钱的空间非常有限
这是一个很值得尝试的策略
随着时间过去近一个月
股价不但持续贯破
甚至跌穿了突破万点之前的盘整区间
距离先前的万点高点
跌幅近500点
加上代表中小型股的贵买指数更是走弱
以及当下我的部位正在赚钱
于是决定继续加码
放空一些中小型股
那时
我的操作已经将国际股市纳入操盘依据之一
2015年
原本非常热的中国大陆股市
到下半年开始急速下挫
几个主要指数在短短不到三个月之间
更是直接腰斩
这也就是015年时很著名的中国股灾
这波股灾不仅连带影响全球股市
台湾股市也跟着恐慌起来
在2015年8月24日
这股恐慌情绪创下当时台股有史以来最大的跌幅
跌点记录
盘中有数百档股票跌停
打开库存列表
只见几乎所有个股空单都跌停板锁死
基于先前我已经看过无数次的个股恐慌急跌
我能够简单地判断
这种状况就代表市场处于恐慌
既然恐慌出来了
后面再跌也很有限了
因此
我做出全数回补的决定
还同步买进当时判定具备基本面且跌幅较重的金融股
很幸运的
我的判断正确
隔天市场果然恐慌结束开始反弹
而这波交易也为自己带来不止一桶金的收益
透过这次经验
我深刻体会到
不管是股市还是各行各业
只要抓到风险报酬不对等的状况
都值得去尝试
这样比较容易站在胜利的一方
第五章 迈向当冲交易之路
台指期与台股当冲
在历经2015年中国股灾过后
虽然我幸运地站在获利的一方
但也因为这段经历
对市场的风险与波动更加尊敬
当时的我还是学生
很容易遇到考试
报告等突发状况
部位常常无法及时处理
但那时当冲风气盛行
于是我开始专心做当冲
在那之前
我的交易中当冲占的比重没那么高
只是偶尔进行当冲交易
不久后
我的绩效就逐步稳定下来
其中原因在于
平常我每天看盘
做交易
研究时留意到短线的走势
惯性
逻辑等方面
不管是交易台纸期还是股票
我一定会实时盯住国际股市
及时国际新闻讯息
这个逻辑很简单
在这里举个极端点的例子
假如某天传出美国总统遭到刺杀的消息
美国股市一定会急速下跌
这时候台湾股市只有跟跌这个选项
有些外资
大户使用高频
价差城市也会随时监控着各国
各商品间的相关系数
当发生这类事件时
他们也会在台湾股市先行避险
因此台湾股市下跌的几率就会更高
所以若不叮国际股市
不就很像蒙住眼做交易吗
经常有人问我
在交易台指期和台股当充时
我还会观察什么
我的回答是
全值股一定是我看盘的重点之一
这不只是逻辑问题
也是规则的问题
大家觉得很神秘
很神奇的加全指数
其实完全不神秘
就只是一个加权平均的数学公式
所以只要看全值股
也能大概知道大盘的状况
再加上加权指数
使台股一发行量加权平均的数学公式计算而成
全值股影响加权指数较大
而台值期依加权指数进行结算
那自然交易台值期就必须关注全值股的动态
尤其在台股开始执行主笔撮合之前更为明显
甚至因此也产生许多的交易机会
台指期是一种衍生性金融商品
最基本的交易逻辑其实就是避险
在台股主笔撮合之前
若台指期突然发生急拉
有高几率是外资同一时间进场买进许多全职股
因为当时非主笔撮合
所以在这种情况下
更容易有滑价 边岸
只在下单到执行之间的价格差异的风险
所以外资会进场先做多台指期货
锁住对应的成本位置
这一点在我们盘中交易
或做台股当充实就很重要
当台指期领先发动时既然已知接下来会有一连串的全职股买单进场而全职股买单左右大盘的气氛连带中小型股也会受影响。在这种情况下,可以执行的策略就举不完了。
例如,一直到下一盘会有人进场买单全职股,因此以这一盘的成本进场。
当别人看到这一盘网上跳时就会进场买进,那这一盘就可以进行当充交易。
二 如果是交易中小型股
这一点更为重要
因为已知全职股要上涨
容易带动整体股市的气氛
这时若你正在进行反向的交易
当然可以率先回补部位
有时操作中小型股的时间差
差到三 五分钟都是有可能的
这又是一个风险报酬不对等的机会
虽然现在股票变成主笔错和交易了
前文提及的时间差也缩短
但其实这种现象还是存在的
海外期货
初学者是很幸福的
有很多东西可以研究
很多东西可以尝试
有时找到一个好的想法是最难的
从前期只看股票
到后来因为开始交易台指期货
台股而学着看海外期货和海外股市
当然
我又是越看越有感觉
又是凭着一股干劲
一头栽下去研究
也开始慢慢做起海外交易
这时候我发现
和国际股市比较起来
台湾的股市和台纸期的波动相对较小
虽然还是可以获利
我仍然逐渐开始将心力转移到海外市场
白天我除了操作台股以外
还会操作日本的日经指数
台股收盘之后休息一下
紧接而来的是欧洲股市开盘
交易德国DUX指数
欧洲蓝筹50
英国富时100指数
编案
本书后文提及海外指数
均为期货
晚上随着美国盘前开始跳动
我开始交易纳斯达克SPP
道琼指数
还有波动非常大的商品类期货
像是清原油
天然气
黄金等
边岸
本书后文提及海外商品
均为期货
虽然当时的资金经过几年累积下来
已经接近八位数
而且我在台股交易市场都已经可以获利了
但我思考住
如果我一天交易三种时段
三个周的股市
假设都练起来都可以获利
那我的资产
累积速度将会是只做一边的三倍速
就因为这个信念
那几年好像都不会累一样
直到2020年位置
我持续地交易海外期货
时间也接近五年之久
这五年
我算是扎扎实实做三份工作
这时我操作的基底
还是最基本的观察各国股市
找出关联性并进行走势的预判
寻找风险报酬不对等的地方
除此之外
也因为国际股市
期货行情波动较大
有时我会利用价格趋势发动时
可能延续几小时到数日的特点
进行顺势交易
做海外股市期货时
要注意的是
不像台湾影响大盘最深的因素
可能包含全职股的涨跌
还有全职股的财报
法说等
在海外市场中
投资者最重视的是数据公布
举凡向是非农就业人数
失业率
物价指数
利率决策
货币银行政策
美国联准会言论
到天然期库存
原油库存变化等各种数据
都会影响股市短期
乃至于长期的走势
因此
这段期间
我花了非常多时间研究与思考
像是钻研当数据低于市场预期
或高于市场预期时
市场上会有什么样的反应
也翻了许多教科书来看
同时我还持续上网查询资料
即以了解各商品间的关联
厘清整个交易逻辑的脉络
例如2020年疫情期间
虽然大家都能预料到非农就业人数将会大减
但当时所有的预估却都不准确
因此数据出来时总是令市场惊讶
这时根据失业率的标高
我会在心里设想一个数
若低于市场预期多少
我可以持有空单多少部位
多少周期等
事先设定好交易的脚本
那段期间
有时数据公布出来若远低于市场预期
美国股市总会在一小时内出现数次的熔断暂停交易
是很好做的大波动时期
只要停损快一些
获利可以跑得非常远
赚赔比非常漂亮
完全可以补足偏低的胜率
在历经每天这样持续不断的交易洗礼之后
我的绩效与资产又顺利的累积上去
当时我采取的是多策略
多商品的交易风格
一旦能培养出大致上均有获利的能力
对于交易的新进平稳会有很大的帮助
还记得2016年时
台股在7月之后的走势
是连续横盘盘整
洗刷了整整半年以上
虽然早上台股市场不好做
但我在其他股市的获利
却能维持住资产状况
免去资产减少的压力
那段时间台股唯一比较大的波动
是同年11月初的美国总统大选
但在大选过后
整体走势又是继续洗刷盘整
美国总统大选这一天
对于短线交易者而言
属于非常好做的日子
像是这种
可预期会出现大波动的交易
每个交易员应该都会非常兴奋
若是做当冲
其实只要把握住一点
就可以掌握不错的获利
也就是说
停损速度快一些
方向对了就抱久一点
因为行情非常大
只要掌控好赔钱的上限
就算胜率低于50
风险报酬
期望值还是非常高
当时因为我主要是做台纸期
海外期货
于是我开启台纸期
小SP
小到小娜的下单价
同时对美国投票结果进行及时监控
还记得一开始希拉蕊领先川普时
全球股市都大涨
而随着后续票开出来
川普的票率跟上之后
股市就应声吓杀
我到现在仍然印象深刻的是
当时有几个海外期货
甚至还跌到触及熔断
暂停交易
当时很有趣的一点是
一开始台纸期走势是落后海外期货的
所以只要看住海外期货交易台纸期
就可以赚到钱
但到后来
反而变成台指期走势领先海外期货
所以我将策略改成
看住台指期交易海外期货
会有这种现象
有个很重要的原因
不外乎跟流动性有关
就像虽然大家觉得小
SP比小到更能反映真实的股市情况
但由于小到本身的流动性比小SP差非常多
相对来说
就是市场情绪反映速度反而会比较快
所以更适合用来观察全市场的情绪方向
同样 在海外期货中
有另一个类似的风险报酬不对等的机会
就是在美国重要数据公布的时候
不过相对于美国总统大选是一整天的波动
数据公布的行情主要波动会是在前几分钟
尤其是在数据公布当下的那一秒内
所以要追这种行情
将会非常持交易者自身的电脑软硬体
报价 下单的速度
当然身在台湾的交易者
肯定是比较吃亏
毕竟报价还要穿过一个太平洋
你再怎么快
顶多也就是台湾最快而已
但这类型的交易策略
还是可以吃得到一些利润
这时候可以利用一些城市辅助
例如数据一公布
就用城市捕捉数据反应的方向
因为这种数据公布的瞬间行情
通常都会明确地给出一个方向
但会是哪一个方向则不一定
举例来说
若原油库存远高于预期
正常情况下这代表供给大于需求
因此价格会下降
所以青原油容易因此蹦出一大根黑K
正因为这一大根黑K的幅度够大
若城市能越快侦测到方向时下跌并赶紧进场
后面还是有利润可以吃
而在台纸期开始有夜盘之后
在美国数据公布的瞬间
比起交易海外期货
反而还不如交易台纸期更轻松
这原因在于台纸期的报价资料
我们不会因地理位置问题而出现接收延迟的情况
算是站在公平起跑点上
让所有交易者去盼软硬体速度
而在台纸期交易的领域中
操作的人和城市又比较少
所以对手相对较弱
有时间差可以做反应
例如当数据公布
海期下跌的时候
你事前设定好城市要做空台纸期
大概至少有四分之一秒的时间差给你做
那这就是一个风险报酬不对等的机会了
抓住风险报酬不对等的机会
不管是交易还是人生
我们都应该要时常去思考
有没有风险报酬不对等的地方
有没有什么办法
可以在不提高成本的状况下
有效地拉高赚赔比
在人生的漫长时间之中
只要能培养思考与把握这种机会的能力
人生就会大有不同
举例来说
看到红灯转绿灯时先等三秒
不仅风险降低
也能提高赚赔比
第一步骤
找方向
如果经常看电视新闻
大家应该都会发现
最频繁出现车祸的情况
莫过于闯红黄灯
抢红黄灯等等
像这么简单的生活环境现象
我们也可以思考看看
这可不可以形成一个策略
第二步骤
思考策略
从小到大
我们想必经常听到这样的宣导
十字路口是最危险的地方
用路人务必小心
再过马路时
必须左看右看
确认有没有人闯
抢红黄灯
十字路口是最频繁发生交通事故的地方
前阵子也因为路人行进斑马线被车撞
成为头条话题
既然遇到抢红黄灯是危险的
也很少听闻在红灯三秒之后
还有车子闯红灯的
最频繁发生车祸的情况
不外乎是在刚变黄灯
或者在转红灯前到灯号变成红灯的瞬间
也就是说
那些用路人要不就是在转灯号的前后急着抢红灯
要不就不会抢了
经过以上的整理
我们可以推论出
是不是在红灯转绿灯后多等三秒
被撞的机会就降低了呢
第三步骤
计算赚赔比
根据常理
虽然多等三秒
但通常不会因为每个红绿灯多等三秒而迟到
最后一样能到达目的地
报酬一样
但风险却能明显降低
减少被抢红黄灯的人撞到
因此
是不是等于在没有提高成本的情况下
赚赔比却提高不少呢
第四步骤
验证参数
要做出决策
我们需要一些参数
如果能找到历史资料
我们所做出的策略便能够更加准确
仔细
严格来说
开发这个策略的时候
我们应该去搜集一个全台湾因为闯红黄灯被撞的资料库
比如说
可能有100件车祸是在红灯一秒后被撞
50件车祸是红灯两秒后被撞
实践车祸是红灯三秒被撞
据此就可以得到平均为
100乘1加50乘2加10乘3
100加50加10
等于1.4375秒被撞机会最高
假设我们分析出来的数据属于常态分配
又可以计算出标准差
再加上三倍标准差
代表99.7的数据是乘一秒内被撞的
这样一来
我们以后只要在绿灯之后多等乘一秒
就可以显著降低这类型被撞的风险
而提高行车行走的转配比
想当然了
我们应该很难取得这样的资料库
没有历史资料
所以我只好用经验分析
依据自己的观察
大概红灯转绿灯两秒内
所有机车骑士就都会冲出去了
如果身为机车骑士的你
在转绿灯后等超过四秒
车子还不开出去
后面其他车子就会巴你了
正如前面推导出这个策略的过程
我们无论身在各行各业之中
都应该尝试发现问题点
并找出常人可能没有察觉到的微小差异
这样一来
无论是职涯或人生
应该都能抓住风险报酬不对等的好机会